and jaime berea
since his return from aaa has been very
good so here is altuve
oh that's gorgeous and that's strike
three
there's a good downward tilt early on
for bria with his slider just a 222
batting average versus slider michael
brantley now
chopper to first walsh is there
and there's two outs
here is correa
luis garcia as it sits he is in a 6.2
innings and you see the 329 era he has
got very good rookie numbers
otani leads it off bottom of the first
we go no score
oh
happy birthday
your wishes come true
rocking it out of the ballpark beautiful
shohei ohtani number 39 out of the yard
halos up one nothing already
if you're looking for big numbers
against this asro right-hander walsh
four for six with two homers and four
runs driven in
that's a line under left center
for the two guys that really have some
good swings against garcia this year
walsh rbi single ohtani home run right
now you got to deal with curiel who is
a master at driving runs in
on cue
marsh there had to recheck to make the
catch and there's one out you really
need a ground ball double play right now
on the ground mayfield
fletcher
jason castro former angel will lead it
off and that's a liner that's curling
[Music]
away behind that play i love that fifth
pump joe adele
i mean berea loving that play you're
looking at a leadoff double
jake myers
to center field
going back at the wall and that ball's
gone no it's out of here that's a whole
run above the yellow line that is the
first major league home run
for jake myers and a big smile on his
face as he touches his own blade it's a
2-1 ball game so there's one out the
astros with three consecutive hits and
the batter now is correa
correa may have gotten under that one a
bit he did and it's to left field
[Applause]
catches made here comes altuve trying to
score now tubey will
that was a great read you're not kidding
he read that off of joe adele jordan
alvarez
and that's ripped to right
brantley will score the astros lead it
three to two jordon goes into second
base with a double bottom three top of
the order
oh
a missile
now you got a stolen base threat
at first base
tony's lead he's running pitching the
dirt he's got it stolen
17 stolen bases time with
his magical year pitching and hitting
two outs ohtani on second walls on first
jose iglesias
here's the o2
that one on the ground
lebas diaz will take the short route and
that will retire the side so the angels
strand a couple
garcia
rocks and fires the 1-2 pitch and it's a
liner and it's caught by altuve head
high here's adam eaton he struck out his
last time up
this one's driven to left field pretty
good jump on it was brantley toward the
line and he makes the catch and gets it
in and there's two outs here's jack
mayfield
on the ground
second base and that will retire the
side
first batter up for the astros
it'll be altuve then brantley and correa
and see how quick his hands are going up
on the elevator pitch
is out
junior guerra in michael brantley at
first
2-2
got him
that's a big big strikeout
jordan alvarez has had some good swings
tonight he's two for two the o2 pitch
and jordan ropes this one that is down
as a fair ball into the corner bradley
coming into third and brantley will be
waved home here's the throw the tag and
he's safe but rbi alvarez with a
three-hit knight the astros lead it
four to two astros with a 4-2 lead over
the angels bottom of the fifth in
anaheim one-two pitch to shohei otani
who led this game off with a home run
and a good pitch and struck him out 3-2
pitch to max stasic one out runners on
the corners
swing and a miss and he struck him out
there's two away iglesias is over two
on the ground slowly hit altuve has to
throw quickly and got his man ready to
retire the side the angels
leave two bases are loaded and nobody
out jake fires right now for him to have
another impactful swing
myers
deep to ride it is a grand slam the
second home run of the night
for jake myers and the second grand slam
in his many nights for the houston
astros my goodness jake myers all hail
jake myers has arrived on the scene
myers is first and second home runs of
his career and that puts someone on base
for shohei ohtani
itani a high fly ball
and mccormick there to make the catch
it's amazing just to hear the reaction
in the stand for everything that show
hey otani hits
this the sound off is bad it's so
different than anybody else
trying to find that strikeout of joe
adele right here with
a couple of runners on two strike pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out
there's two away
on the ground altuve
that'll do it for the angels in the
eighth inning as they strand two more
the astros lead at eight to two jared
walsh has been on base three times
[Applause]
hit hard on the ground but right at
julie and that will do it
the astros take the first two of this
three-game series on a night that jake
myers will never
forget